I'm Patrick bid David your host of value
tainment today we are with my good
friend grant and Cardona
mr. 10x on Miami uh uh uh welcome to my
it's good to be here man this is a
pretty pretty good city or living in
your Bible thank you it's pretty alright
as well that you're not paying taxes
we're in California so there's a little
bit of jealous with your stay don't have
to be there we don't have to be that
we're you know it's it's unbelievable
that you would drive across country
California would still grab money from
you why they're not making your trip
better they're not adding quality to
your business they're not doing anything
is anybody from the state of California
come to you and say let me show you how
to make your business better but we have
great weather so uh the beaches I'm
gonna be there this weekend it's
thirteen and a half percent we that well
I treat California like a prostitute
tell us tell us what to go in there use
it and get out of town that's how this
video gets started and the product is
nobody all right thank you say just use
it and leave oh this is this is this is
right off the bat he's teaching some of
the single guys tips tell earlier you
have to be her pickup lines member would
come back to the background yeah I want
to start off with a very serious
question yeah i'ma start off with a very
serious question cat what is your secret
to being the Benjamin Button of business
man every time I see you look younger
every single time but man why do you how
do you take care of yourself you know I
mean that's that's that's for another
show I think there's people wouldn't
even believe what keeps me young but I
think they got it a little bit huh a
part of nothing well me you know I think
I'm in the game okay i'm in the game I
think when I when I'm in my game
completely and like on purpose and doing
what I'm supposed to be doing I'm most
alive and I'm youngest at those moments
you know I know people that knew me 20
years ago and they're like do your
actually look younger and act younger
than you were 20 years why do you think
that is because I mean I'm in the game
I'm in the game of change and expansion
and expansion means life really it means
to live if you look up the word
live our life as a physics term it means
to expand if you look up expand it means
to grow and change and when I'm in that
part of the cycle then then I'm
rejuvenating something and I know if you
know older guys are like oh I'm not
going to check into that yeah I don't
need to do that there on the end of
their cycle and they start showing in
their face in their life and their kids
and so I'm still in the create so how do
I go about not subscribing to that
mindset I'm getting older you know I'm
getting tired of like hurts all that how
do you not subscribe to that yeah I just
like man I just want to be in the game I
mean I've participated in the downward
cycle and I know how it made me feel and
I just want to avoid those feelings so I
like feeling good I like feeling
youthful I like the excitement I like
the fear you know that fears of
priceless feel I like the edge I like
finding people saying man the way you
open this video was wrong
see I like that like I need to find that
edge to experience life so let me ask
this question then so let's go into this
question yeah because that's that's very
important what you just said so how do
you balance this is probably one of the
most difficult things I see with
entrepreneurs and you don't hear a lot
of people talking about this there's a
lot of a key to success all yes okay we
got how do you balance not given a crap
about all the judgment you're getting
yeah and yet still being likeable and
sincere because there's something that I
don't give a crap but people don't like
them right right there are something
that are very sincere but they're afraid
of what other people think how do you
balance the two together you know it's
it's a it's a trick it's like kind of
like chaos it's a bit of chaos happening
with a little bit of management and I
don't I don't think in terms of managing
things much or balanced when I think of
the word balance I think of work of
managing something trying to trying to
make something a perfect fit we you and
I talked about this before by being
perfect you know it's really a kind of a
cop-out but you know look at the way for
me to do is to go wide I want if I can
find seven billion people I know for
sure I can get half of them to lightning
you know I think half the people on
planet earth would like me how fun would
like you okay and the other half hey you
know maybe not never gonna have an
opinion of me or maybe they're gonna
like dislike me but either way I'm gonna
get paid whether they like you or not as
long as I wouldn't expand me as long as
I keep expanding my base
you know there's something I could be
perfect for everybody in the room half
the people still gonna be like nice to
cockys to this he's too bad I spent I'm
57 years old I spent 30 years trying to
please people
I wonder the shift-tab I know but
nothing man when I finally said you know
what I'm done dude the more energy I
spent trying to please people make you
happy them happy mom happy daddy happy I
still couldn't make everybody happy I'm
like you know what I'm done dude I'm
gonna make me happy I'm gonna run my gig
this is my life you know I want to
create the life I want for me and if you
don't like that life you probably don't
even like your life because that's the
people getting up criticizing me it's
okay so now let's go back
that's a great question up yeah I was
just curious because you know a lot of
times you see people that are
uncomfortable like they feel like that
to please everybody yeah and you don't
ever see their full potential and I'm
talking trying to please everybody yeah
sometimes they get you know to relations
they try to please everybody business
they try to appease everybody you can't
do it yeah so Grant who was grant in
high school that's what I'm really
curious he was a guy trying to please
everybody man in high school yeah like
the first year of high school I guess
that's the 12th grade not worth good
10th grade 10th grade first grade I
could have been I could have been school
uh they nominate me for most successful
in high school everybody loved me the
girls loved me the frickin football team
loved me everybody loved me okay the
next year the next two years I couldn't
be they could not I could not win dog
catcher because once I got comfortable
with everybody liking me or whatever
part of me they liked then I started
showing my true colors and then Ellison
I didn't fit anymore
see I wasn't free to be me as long as
there was a popularity contest
you weren't free to be you as long as it
was a popularity not but I had to be
them because I had to be popular under
their guidelines okay I had to dress the
way they dress talk the way they talk I
had to do the protocol thing
I was a slave to popularity and I was
like man I can't even do this I'm an
identical twin so I think part of being
identical twin is when you're brought up
everything is a comparison who's smarter
who's taller who's bigger who's faster
right and so I was I've been searching
for my independence I think probably
everybody goes through this but I was
searching for my independence the whole
time as much as I love my brother I
still didn't want to be compared to him
forever and our two other people in my
field and you know today as I as a grown
up so popularity was a trap for me and
it don't pay man like most popular
people don't get paid look at Kanye West
people love him or hate him look at his
wife people hate that woman
nan stuff we know our stuff we know her
so so look if you're gonna be look at
Obama okay on the other end of the
spectrum hate to put all three of those
people in the same but look you know
people hate Obama he's the President of
the United States for eight years men
the most p.m. the guy was a community
leader so if you can give people if you
can just be you and if you have a real
message you know something authentic and
then you can express that you know I
think you're going to at least be happy
once you realize you were going to go
into sales business like when did to
transition into sales and business gets
I did I had to sell I had to sell to pay
to pay for a hiding to have some money I
was in a refinery town of labor town and
there was no jobs one other this is what
a refinery time your time at Louisiana
this is a chance a refinery town there
based on oil and gas and refining oil
and gas and rednecks in town you know
very very southern
I say redneck with a lot of admiration
by the way and it was bad I've been beat
up by so many rednecks - it's
unbelievable okay because what what I
would do in high school is I go take
their girl right you know on the ladies
man right and I'd go take their girl
right and then they'd boom beat me up
the next day I'm like
but I hit on that last night okay and a
button I hit on me again I'm like dang
and this is hard being popular you know
it's hard being good-looking so I'm
working in this refinery count I didn't
like the labor I hated the hard work I
hated the dirty thing right and I hurt
myself I almost cut my foot off at the
refinery and I needed money and my uncle
said I'd get in sales you can make money
in sales I hated sale how old were you I
was uh seventeen seventeen yeah I'm
selling clothes how does job is selling
clothes selling furniture
I sold fish I sold seafood fish fish man
he sold seafood do that so red fish I
made more money selling red fish what
what I would do is I was on this this
boat that would we go we got to the
refineries about 60 miles offshore and
we would deliver supplies I was a supply
boat there was three of us on it and I
was a bit of a cook and one day when our
free time I hey I'm gonna fish so we
dropped these lines these are 200-foot
lines they have probably 75 hooks on put
it down and get down to the bottom and
I'd start dropping it out of here oh did
I pull him up a hole 75 fish on one line
couldn't pull him I had to get three
people to pull them up so we put them in
the freezer we end up with I mean I
don't know hundreds and hundreds of
pounds of fish and I sell them all the
way home when two weeks later we get
back on shore and I'm driving to my
apartment that I'm paying $300 a month
for it and I sell these fish well I make
more money selling these fish and and
that I made two weeks of working hard
labor on
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna learn how to
sell is is that what caused you to go
from hating sales at first to love I'll
go ahead sales because I was sucked at
it dude the reason I sold all those fish
and made the money is cuz the freakin
ice was melting so I was forced I didn't
learn the lesson I was forced because of
the urgency to get rid of the fish so I
had a knock on doors because if I didn't
freaking sell this fish today it was
gonna go bad so to me I was looking at
that long way right had a deadline then
I didn't start professional sales for
another two years and I was awful at it
couldn't talk to people introverted
professional sales what was a product it
was cars automobiles yeah a very hard
sale if that's in Louisiana in Louisiana
in Louisiana yeah do it very very did I
wake our sails so what happened from
them well the first thing that happens
is you get dropped into this environment
where you're around other car sales and
this 25 years ago so imagine the car
business people don't like going to car
dealers today a magic 25 years ago was
even worse and so I'm with these guys
they sitting around or smoking
cigarettes you know that drinking coffee
and they're complaining this is the car
salesmen in Louisiana man but business
is bad traffic's bad products bad we
don't have the right products customers
are cheap it's awful and I'm stuck in
this environment this cesspool of
negativity and I'm trying to learn a new
trade so how do you do that you know you
basically do it for a week you have a
bunch of successes in the first week and
then the next thing you know you have
now submitted to this environment this
cesspool this old soup of negativity and
it drag me down with it and so I did two
years of being drugged down into the
freakin car sales environment I hated
hated you had many tons of your stories
about that in car sales all the time the
environment of course said I was
interesting sometimes yeah yeah yeah
some bad habits give up I hated
environment but you know there's a lot
of bad environments right no down yeah I
was just in Prague and a cab driver
picks me up and we were coming out of
the Four Seasons and the cab driver
comes out I get his car I'm like hey how
you doing today he's like I'm sad
that's his opening man I said you say to
you yeah you said and my wife's with me
she's hot and uh she is man and so so we
get the cab that got sad my wife's like
what are you sad about she's all inputs
empathetic and I went I'm freaking
cracking but she's it in the Czech
Republic man but you're sad about it you
got a couple Americans coming out of the
Four Seasons walking into your car you
lucky
damn job right he doesn't know I'm a
motivational guy so in my white side
what do you said about I said I have to
work like you said you have to work did
you lucky you got a job man I said what
would you rather be doing you want to go
home you want to be with your wife no
I'm single
no wonder you're so what are you gonna
do man so this is this is in a country
where they don't even know man that you
can get up and do something spectacular
with life I mean they've literally given
up because the government's been taken
care of how do you shift that mindset of
entitlement to into knowing that you can
rise up and do it on your own I don't
think you I don't think you shift him I
think he's done so so yeah his kid's 27
years old he's done you don't think
you're just a dead man
you don't think and shift them so you
don't think so but well no not not I
can't shift it I understand that but but
you look at some of the guys that are in
an environment maybe they've been baby
by their mother maybe their baby by a
family man maybe they may be in a family
would mean this guy was basically he was
maybe bad a communist regime shut his
whole like for 60 years they just didn't
have a choice so he quit he became
apathetic okay so the the opposite of
the word live is actually I would look
this up last night succumb it means to
succumb he had hit the opposite a lip
which is to come so so he has succumbed
to the conditions he can't if I told him
man you could actually go out and do
something day I'm telling he's a dead
man and why do people buy that why is it
so easy to sell that concept why does it
win vote it's constant man it's it's a
relentless it's not just a politician
selling it that I'll take care of you
but if you turn the TV on it's one of
the reasons we created the studio
Network if you turn the TV on you're
gonna hear bad news bad news bad news
that's bad enough but then the ads that
follow the bad news did the ads are you
sick yet do your legs hurt
you can't get an erection I mean it's ad
after ad after ad about why you have
actually felt its kind of going back to
what we're talking about right now why
am I so alive it's because I want to be
in the upward cycle regardless of my age
I want to be in the upward cycle of
creation so how do you how do you
prevent from falling towards being tired
of of falling for the handouts how do
you do that you I think you have you
really been it you have to control your
environment your culture like who's been
at home and it worked like if you walk
in my office I don't know if any my
staff came out and said hello to you you
could feel about absolutely we have
people that have come in this is where
the sixth floor here they come into the
bottom of the building they could feel
the pulse from here right we've had
people come up to the sixth floor and
what happens up here any white man they
can feel that's a culture that means I
got to get rid of some people that don't
have that we have a lot of turnover here
I'm proud of that okay I'm proud of my
turnover cuz I see the guy says man I
got so many loyal employees they've been
with me so long you bragging or
complaining what what's the deal I'm not
sure what you're saying oh yeah because
we keep people why why do you keep
people that are dead man my job to grow
the company so I need to control my
environment to keep positive people that
don't want to be entitled they do want
to pay the price that are willing to
suffer a bit in a different way because
that kid in the taxi suffering going
back to trying to please everybody well
whatever he stood of either by keeping
keeping everybody you know what I mean
is when you see have a high turnover
yeah you can't please everybody and keep
everybody with you all the time
dude they don't fit here so what do you
look for let's just say you're sitting
there and interviewing somebody what do
you look for can you reach this would be
the question I'm hiring salespeople yeah
yeah can I really in an interview tell
you're a stud or do I only want steady
California you can't not about the
California you can't even ask him
anything you can't ask age can add sex
you can't ask preferences you can't ask
are you on drugs you can't ask you know
what do you do at night let me see your
Facebook page you can't ask anything to
you in California and in Miami really I
can't actually find out who somebody is
so how do you go about judging we create
a TV show to do it so we created TV show
called
whatever it takes the ultimate job
interview
where we set up an interview process and
told people this is not a job interview
this is a TV show okay the people that
win this is another job interview this
is a TV show and when it's a TV show
dude I can ask you everything I can take
your phone grab your phone in the
interview and start going through your
pictures give me your password man part
of the interview broke and I'm freaking
on camera collecting the content but
it's not an interview show now I can ask
you everything okay maybe I can ask that
question now because it's a TV show
okay you ever done drugs we were going
through a guy's with you and 460 people
460 people we interviewed in this
process we allowed 90 of them to come
through
I grabbed phones if every one of them
and start going through it this guy's
got oxycodone pictures of oxycodone on
his phone okay
we go through his bags let me see your
bag man I grabbed his bag I pull his
stuff out he's got 16 oxycodone tablets
after you lied to me no I don't use
drugs and he's got him in his freakin
bag in a little cellophane what do I
know right now he's not my god you ask
these questions yeah there's a TV show
me so I know now I know now okay then we
cut him okay I end up with seven or
eight guys that I want to start freaking
running through the program I do you
have whatever it takes that's what I
want to know do you have whatever it
takes because if you're going to be
successful it's not the education it's
not job bringing you know you and I have
completely different stories about where
we came from
do you have whatever it takes when it's
tough when it's hard when it's scary
will you do whatever it takes to take
care of your wife your kids ethically to
take care of yourself you know got sixty
pounds overweight good why you
overweight man I can ask that interview
now you know I can go down and look at
their car find dr. kieny and take care
of their car
look you can't take care of your car how
you can take care of your job you are
dead meticulous in your hiring process
no but I'm looking at a lot of people
got it she's oh and I'm will did best
money you see you said you see Trent on
quality and talent like is there a trend
Reese I look for boom boom Trent has
been like this for 200 years man you
know your your your grandparent
and my grandparents knew about work they
didn't [ __ ] about it
Sun came up they started working Sun
went down they might have stopped that's
what they might've stuff they might have
stung eidest okay no the reason they
stopped is because the candles went out
it but frickin they didn't have any wax
for life so what's changed if it's going
down look look now look at media man hey
and see look at the media man the media
is like 800 TV channels come at you you
don't have to do anything you mean you
can't get up to get a remote anymore you
get pissed off if you got a freakin fine
your remote today day on my damn remote
ma'am my remote the battery sir can't
even get up internally on TV the
computers everything is delivered to us
you know I got apps to order nothing man
people don't go anywhere you don't
remember your phone number you don't
remember your map okay my wife my wife
will not she does not know where we're
at
I'm like baby don't look at the freaking
map in the phone man you got to learn
where the exit is so you can know where
we are
right otherwise the awareness just keeps
going down is that is that a it if it's
a bad thing so how do you get to 10x but
how do you fight against that how do you
fight it if the work ethic is going down
so I'm 9:00 to 5:00 9:00 to 5:00 was the
thing that came out with Ford Motor
Company working on i-95 I saw that 95
movie you're my 95 not the 95 movie I'm
not I'm in 95 hours 95 that's what I
thought 95 boys people like I don't do
9:00 to 5:00 I'm like will you do 100
I do 95 hours every week I can't spend
the money I made in my lifetime okay and
capped I suppose if you can need five
billion dollars tomorrow five big ones I
would be here tomorrow on time do my
deal because it's the create man is to
create so like you guys are watching
looking at Facebook I want to bang
Facebook I want to create on Facebook I
don't want to have I don't want to be a
spectator I mean part of the 10x was
like get off get out of the stands and
back on the field be on the field man
that's where the game that's where you
get it that's where you get to hit right
that's where you get the win you get to
score the cameras the paparazzi looks at
you you want that
want that in my life you know that's my
life is not in the stands so talk about
the boat 10x obviously you know the way
you and I got connected is one of our
guys in our company he swears by the
book time yeah yeah he tells everyone
everyone's got to read this book that
looks magical man so we got connected
talk about you want to write the book
okay I'm gonna tell you right off of the
first four books that I've written this
is the one when I was done I was like
yeah whatever
swear to God okay first book I wrote
took three hours to write this book took
I don't know maybe three months 90 days
or something and it I just didn't like I
oughtn't fill in it big time right and I
got done I'm like it's alright did this
book every day I hear people I mean man
that book woke me up that book changed
my life that book has caused me to go
from making 3,000 bucks a month to
making 60,000 bucks in the same month
not even do anything different the money
was always there a guy told me last
night the money was there the whole time
I just couldn't see it because like my
eyelids were like I was squinting at
life and this thing just like open my
eyes up to say wow how much could I do
and the 10x rule is basically about look
you need to make goals that are giant
not like your mom and dad said your mom
and dad said you know tone it down tone
it down you know have some reasonable
how many of you heard that reasonable
goals something attainable and that what
happens is when the goal is attainable
it's no longer exciting because if you
can go get it easily you're gonna take
it for granted if you can go get it
easily gonna take you for granted
yeah so I wake up this morning there's
no Malcolm on refrigerator
I don't drink milk but I like milk to
make froth for my cappuccino and I like
the froth the really thick so it takes a
lot of milk right and I'm now pissed off
man there's no freaking milk it's not
that there's no milk dude I want the
melt now and I want it now more than
ever because it's not in there so if
it's attainable if a million dollars was
attainable to everybody wouldn't be
worth anything and by the way it is
attainable
so I believe that the bigger the giant
the more unattainable the goal is okay
the the least likely if it's real for
you the least likely you are to give up
on that goal I think a lot of the
reasons why you see people going down is
because the goals are so low why would I
be excited who could possibly be excited
about making enough money to pay their
bills so one of the things I like about
you Granth is is it one of the things
that you when we had the interview I
mean we really enjoy the time with you a
couple months ago one of the things I
really liked about you and the reason
why I sent people tell me hey who should
I follow on YouTube or a Facebook or
Twitter and all that's I said you got a
follow grant and I'll tell you my number
one reason why I tell everybody to
follow you I got a top 20 to 25 Twitter
accounts to follow my website Patrick
wavy.com and I tell them to follow you
as one of them because I love people who
are currently building yeah yeah there's
someone I'm saying I'm currently engaged
in building not talking about hey what
they did what they how do you ask
somebody that's watching this we got a
lot of YouTube experts you know this
yeah how about the podcasters podcasters
they're the guys interviewed they don't
need to be the expert right right right
you're hiring the eggs for like a John
Newman's he's not the expert right right
yes not very - he's done a great job I
respect that yeah but you got some of
these guys yeah that they've just read
books yeah they've never built anything
and they get on YouTube and they see out
to do this you have to do that yeah how
does one tell the two apart to say these
are the real deal is of TLC Brown bro
you need to see their bank account you
need to see their freakin where they
live what they're driving okay you need
to see their employees you guys are
grabbing all these people as gurus and
mentors you need to look a little deeper
who is this guy for real because look
there's no regulation on me saying I'm
an expert I can be an expert on
everything okay in fact I am okay just
put me on Fox pickup lines I'm an
introvert on it you know oh you know I'm
an expert on the freaking up
coming election okay now the fact is you
need to look a little deeper after the
guy says he's a YouTube or social media
expert and then you look and find out
he's only got 2,000 people in a Facebook
page so he might be an expert of getting
money from you about something you don't
know about social media but he hadn't
built his own freaking and this kills me
man
I see I know professional speakers that
have been out touring the world for 25
years ever build anything there's no
company man they owe to employees for 25
years all they've been doing is getting
fees you look around here I've got 55
employees and it's one freakin building
right here dude so on tape I'm figuring
out how to build a business a real
business and then multiply those
businesses so I can create more
opportunities for people but but I like
what you're asking how do you how do you
know you need to look deeper and the
reason I say you need to look at hey
what's what's their money like what's
their house like what's their car like I
mean what's the rest of it I'm talking
about material things because material
things when you start accumulating
success it's going to show up in some
material things there's no way you know
that's not going to show up somewhere so
you need to look at the flow over should
be happy Tony Robbins create an
unbelievable business what I know about
Tony is this he has created a business
okay that that creates a lot of funds I
like that and it wasn't sales he did a
little bit me I had to sale Jojo some of
that stuff that he did so he brought
some of that experience
unbelievable marketing guy yeah okay I'm
not the firewalker guy I'm not looking
at walk on fire but unbelievable
marketing guy for now if I want to I
would I would watch Tony for marketing
more than I would for motivation
personally see that's the way I would
Rob from him
you know John Dumas I would Rob I don't
want John's money I want my money
but I would Rob from John and say his ID
it was brilliant how he collaborates
with so many people and it brings it
brings him up you know through the
collaboration so so here's here's
another question with that here's
another question with that so you got
you got guys like a Suze Orman and Dave
Ramsey all the experts online better
going around telling everybody you ought
to do this and you
to do that you ought to do this and
they're not really building anything
they're just putting fear into everybody
yeah yeah what did way there's no you're
gonna know both these guys have made a
lot of money okay Pro brilliant
marketers really I mean Dave Ramsey's
got a freaking awesome I mean he's made
a ton of money I don't want to trade my
network with Dave Ramsey I just tell you
that okay I just know for sure now now
let me say this okay let me say this
what they plugged into what they both
plugged into is the fear in America
mm-hmm okay
Susie says don't spend your money
spending is never your problem debt is
not your problem and day he plays the
other thing
she's don't spend it in days like don't
bar it okay both of them are wrong
because what you need to know is you
need to know how to create it spinnings
not a problem in depth not a problem
they make money off of a fear and the
networks are built on fears you know
well of course
what's the chicks name the the blonde
the crazy wacko chick on the HLN number
she's on HLN not CNN but the sister she
does all the the crime stuff okay you
got it done this Chris she's a whack
whack man Nancy Grace Nancy Grace
the total fear monger right okay look at
the chick on Fox no judge what's her
name
Judge Judy or whatever what dude it's
all about fear man and and so like those
are points of contraction that they're
about don't borrow don't spend okay
don't go outside your house don't talk
to strangers everything is a contraction
point I want to expand and grow I don't
want to contract you know I want to
expand I don't want to save my money to
get rich and end up being an old man
mm-hmm
you and I were brought up like that
mm-hm I nee save you money save you
money you him okay you just get old I
mean you you probably know some some
people in your lineage that that they
saved every penny they had dude when
they die they're like everybody's like
oh yeah and all that money would spin up
idiot why are you saying all this man
because you're worried about the ability
to create new income okay oh great
answer by the way grant uh you interview
a lot of people yeah so when you
interview a lot of people who don't know
you maybe they haven't followed you and
you in
you people people always look at the
person being interviewed as a more
powerful than the person interview uh
what most people don't know is your
networks your hundred million dollar guy
you're not a $500,000 guy you're not a
million dollar guy you've got a hundred
million dollar net worth and well Google
Google doesn't have a quite right but it
may even be more than that but I was
with Kiyosaki this past Tuesday uh-huh
that is in Arizona rich dad hit yeah
yeah I love I love him great stuff he
teaches yeah he said one of the most
interesting things about this and I'm
curious what you think about this he
said one of the most interesting things
about he said when the government prints
money and they printed roughly three
trillion dollars in the last few years
when the government prints money it
affects the middle-income low-income guy
yeah but the guy who's got money and
credit he gets rich because he goes out
and borrows money yeah if you could say
a philosophy because there's two things
one is making a lot of money there's a
lot of guys a make a lot of money but
their investments yeah and there's guys
that have investments but don't make a
lot of money how do you balance the two
where you're making a lot of money but
you're also increasing this on the back
end because this is a party got to pay
attention to yeah would you say about
that uh what I do is I bucket money so I
have I have my wealth you know that I
have my wealth and what I do I play this
little trick with myself I've done it
from 25 years I take all my income my
income comes in and I push I'm broke all
the time I break myself here and push
everything I don't diversify investments
I think diversification is for okay
sorry ladies
I respect that and everything but I
think it's four little babies little
baby money okay I take all the freaking
free money I got not push it in this one
deal so I know they say you go with the
Andrew Carnegie philosophy dude I put
all your eggs in one basket just make
sure they don't fall I make sure that
basket is frickin solid I like the Ark
the Noah's Ark okay and so what happens
over here is I'm broke now so I got to
create new money to pay my bills I got
to create new money all the time like do
you'll see you'll see me I will get as
excited about this $25
day-timer it's doing a 25 million dollar
apartment you because this is my
survivability this month and allows me
to create brilliant well for next
brilliant
so I'm broke all the time brilliant yeah
brilliant so it's constantly still
selling your bread and butter and not
becoming too big cuz that this is this
is another thing that impresses me about
grant I really like the fact that as
much money the cars all the stuff that
you gotta pee I know you know when you
see some of the videos they do
you're still a pretty cool cat humble I
think you're cocky but you're cool Kenny
still ha
how do you stay humble I mean you Kim
Saudis guys coming they they talked in
they ask you some questions and you're
thinking to yourself you don't need not
two hundred grand ref your name how do
you stay humble I don't know I don't
know if I am humble I mean I don't
consider myself a humble person but but
I don't think if I ever say I'm Huckle I
would I nor would they say I'm nice
people would did not say I'm a nice I
wouldn't call you arrogant I think some
people would say did you guys - cocky -
very probably you haven't be Helen
nobody what do you guys think on
periscope in my cocky and arrogant but I
don't mean to be I'm just alive I think
I'm being mislabeled by people because
because I'm just telling you the truth I
mean the water let me refer yeah it's
not humble likeable well thank you well
if you're so likable if you're likable
think to some people see I don't care
because I know this if somebody doesn't
like me it's a more about them than it
is about me you know if somebody doesn't
like my driving my roles this morning
I'm driving over here you know and then
somebody look sober I know there's
somebody's not gonna like me driving a
Rolls just you can't like that [ __ ] man
right I know that but that's saying more
about them that is saying about me and
him okay uh you're not you when people
hate on me my wife it kills my wife
she's like oh my god I hate they say
that about you baby it didn't say
anything about me they're saying about
themselves that's not about me or us
it's about them
oh you're so humble grant well that's
saying more about what you think about
humility because I don't think I'm
at all I don't even think about humility
III don't it doesn't even register to be
humble as a way to live life because for
me that would require me to be something
else you know that would require to be
something else that's not part of your
DNA is that what you're saying to worry
I don't know about my DNA cuz I'm not
know meaning it's not it's not part I
don't think about that I think about
being me that's my point and and you
know the meek shall inherit the earth
I think that thing people misunderstand
a lot of this stuff man they take one
line out of a big book the Cystic the
meek will inherit the earth that's one
line man okay there's also a whole bunch
of [ __ ] in there about work you know and
about if you don't work it's evil so
like you gotta you gotta say what you
can't take one piece and if the meek are
gonna inherit this planet I guarantee
it's gonna be a garbage dump by the time
the ship okay you'll be left over yes
it's like you're gonna be patient be
patient right be patient patient you be
patient
you get crumbs yeah okay cuz guys are in
a hurry you're pickin up the good [ __ ]
and you're getting left with the
leftovers is it important become a
million to become wealthy I think I
think everybody should first of all
everybody's gonna have a million bucks
you make fifty grand a year and you do
that for 20 years you made a million
dollars so million dollars in the target
target now you need money you need the
rich and you need to get wealthy okay
and rich is why yourself to wealthy why
is that
mm Adele okay uh he's what he's saying
you're 33 minutes in nineteen seconds
what does it matter new people don't
care spectators don't care people that
watch it don't care when they're being
entertained they don't care about time
what is wrong with you Mario - Mario I
wonder yes what oh my god no he's
actually married he's got two kids
single guys over here this guy that's
single
why don't we the transition in today
let's do that let's handle this last
question hello we're gonna come back
useful Britney you're also gonna be okay
rich is important but let me tell you
what's really important wealth is more
important than rich wealth wealth is
where you want to be rich is an insult
to wealthy elaborate rich is just you
make a lot of money that's not well that
does not entitle you
huh front end back yeah God okay you
you're rich I've got a big house you've
got a big car you people say that you're
rich wealth is affluence is affluence in
every area it's not about being rich
when I hear a guy say I'm rich that's
good that means you got money when I
hear guys say I'm wealthy I'm like a
Barbie girl you got it all what
categories well you got all help family
kids why don't put it on mush if he went
in if Donald Trump I don't think Donald
Trump's a wealthy guy okay I just don't
think he is I I don't think Donald's a
happy guy it's just a dead dead look
happy I think he's running to be a
president one day he ain't running to be
President running a marketing system Rd
and marking this guy might run - is that
a you is this you and not imagine
ousting it right nothing break your
throne announcing my party must be a
marketing campaign okay
I might even market put me in a that'll
probably do very good in Las Vegas
better probably do get a few markets
okay so so so so uh going back and
talking about this whole money thing and
rich and wealthy thing yeah let's let's
talk the income part and we'll wrap it
up with a few fun things here income how
important is it to make seven figures
today we talk fronted this the rich part
yeah yeah but how important is it to
make seven figures today because you
hear a lot of time with people so I need
to go into this I need to go into that I
need to do this I need to do what that
guy is doing and I can't make it if I
work for this guy can't make it if I
work for that guy how important is it
today for someone saying I need to go
make a decision to make seven figures
well I think I think the answer to that
question would be like if you're making
40 grand you don't you know you need to
have that million dollar figure out
there but the first thing you got to do
is you got to go from 40 to 60 you know
that's what I did I went from 40 to 60
and okay man can I can I add another 10
then I say okay I'm a good 70 grand a 70
grand okay
I get to 100 today the real target you
need to be at I mean just to start
getting where you're like okay I'm
getting my head above water is about a
bucket of water you need 125,000 bucks
to be above water just like those
breathing room dude like like wait wait
a minute I'm actually working that one
day I would have a little money left
over this is the problem with Suze
Orman's save money look if you make four
grand a month okay and you try to save
part of that four grand you can only
save so much we know for sure you can
only save up to four thousand of it
that's if you're not paying any taxes
it's easier to make another form than to
say for it's impossible actually to make
four and save the whole four it's
impossible you can't feed you what you
wouldn't go to eat right so it's
impossible if people are trying to do
the impossible right now they're trying
to save what they make dude it's easier
just to make another four grand there's
no shortage of money there's no shortage
of money on this planet there's plenty
of money you said four trillion dollars
has been frickin manufactured they'll
they're going to make every dollar on
this planet has been manufactured not
four trillion on the why everybody's all
excited about it I like every freaking
penny ever produced on this planet was
manufactured by somebody so you got it
first decided there's no shortage you
know clear if you're thinking about what
your daddy thinks a lot of money is and
and get rid of thinking that you make
enough you don't nobody does and then
start thinking okay my first target
should be honored 25 that gets you in
the top 5% of all the earners on planet
Earth okay if you're on 125 grand a year
that's 10,000 bucks a month top 5%
planet Earth planet Earth bro you on
your own taught your you're at the party
now at least your you've been invited to
the party
of prosperity on planner I found that
money man I'm talking bout taking care
your kids where you want to send it to
school you're gonna have to buy a car
you probably need a house at some point
you need clothes you got to have food
you're gonna have an emergency we need
some freaking dough I'm not doing about
money right so now if you want to get
the big leagues now you got to start
thinking about these other numbers 250
400 a million
million a month that's when it gets
exciting see ya [ __ ] I did a sloppy man
ah okay so we've had a good time here
let me guess always have a good time
with you hoppity books top three books
of all time top three books of all time
and there's a Brit so many books I mean
I don't whatever comes to mind even if
one of the first ones they crush it
crush it I love Gary Vaynerchuk crush it
um thinking Grow Rich I mean definitely
uh greatest salesman in the world God's
will you know you know you still read a
lot yeah try to clip a book away what's
the last one you read what's the name of
this book I'm reading right now damn I
just forgot it
it's about management have you read
snowball buy warm but now that's a very
good book yeah I just finished it this
week okay so for now I recommend it okay
very cool ah look far single guys up
here I got to a single questions for you
our buddy Paul yeah we took up to where
do we go to a couple nights ago we went
bang goes okay he can't get enough of it
there's only going to strip genre you
gotta quit the porn okay you know what
point the porn industry was created Paul
because people people lower their
expectations there okay this is why the
point is she was created Paul says man I
want that hot chick over there okay and
he sees her and he goes up to her and
she's like nine pass and then what
happens he's like okay I'll go to this
chick that wasn't your on your menu man
you know if I if I go to a restaurant I
said hey I want the freakin uh I want
the Stone Crabs nor like oh it's out of
season somebody got to have stone crabs
in Miami right now man who's got him
okay I don't want to drop down to shrimp
and that's what Paul did okay he dropped
down he dropped it he dropped again he
dropped again next thing you know he's
at home by himself
freaking that bother you want to show
your face in this video
if you don't have friends entertainer
taro Kiyosaki this is a very good friend
okay sake with directness vote we had a
good time with him too so give him give
him one one pick-up line give a good
pick-up line Paul one pick-up line for
you from the master closer here uh dude
well I'm the thing I would tell you just
don't drop your standards bro go let's
decide what you want P okay decide what
you really want right and get it man I
mean jay-z says he's got a great line in
a in one of his songs he says look I
want a wife you know that that was his
game baby you know there's a guy that
knows how to create the life he wants
okay look like I wanted a wife I had it
written down I want a wife that every
man everybody that I have once them but
they know she they can't cuz she's
ethical I got that way okay my buddies
love her man she's fun to be with
so you guys got to decide what you want
man how much money you want what kind of
spouse you want you know how exciting is
you know it's never you never a dull
moment yeah come in here come in the
shot come on we want to get Paul in the
shot or noble beautiful to get in [ __ ]
yeah probably everything let's get her
in the [ __ ] I look you guys got it the
point is to quit settling okay the fact
that I curse and talk like this if
somebody if somebody if somebody uh you
know like you you're like all that was
wrong you said that you're saying more
about you than you're saying about me
okay I also say ain't
look right and I say ain't ain't a word
yeah I said any and then I say I'm the
only one here to gets paid to speak
shuts me down dude this chick wouldn't
go out with me for 13 months Paul 13
months okay now when she said no to me
bro all I did was call her back again I
didn't I didn't go to any real pain yeah
not let's turn it around look everyone
so I got a friend back there Britney she
knows she's in trouble right now cuz
yeah she says she's in Miami
you know garlic and girl yeah
entrepreneurs yes tough chance she's
that number by the way the 125 number
she's in that none yes what she that
works hard those great things and
financial services how does she find a
stub like you look may I be a gold
digger if I were you I don't know what
the whole big deal is people like people
somebody asked Elena D&I do you a gold
digger like what you digging for do
what's wrong with that
why has that become a bad thing I've
been I'm taking for gold every frickin
day in my life
why wouldn't you go dig for gold if I
was going out with a guy Brittany I'd
say hey you see your financials buddy
okay I ain't going out what I got is
broke I'm not going out with a guy that
can't freakin Bank money can't pay his
credit cards how is he going to take
care of your kids
if he can't freakin Bank so I would
change the places you go I still going
to the country clubs to charity events
dude I be freaking digging gold there's
nothing wrong with a woman because look
landing a goddess that's a great ship
landing a goddess rich one thing okay
staying with him and creating the life
he wants that's a different deal I mean
I'm not saying you would dig for gold
just go for the money and not find
somebody you love you want the whole
deal that's wealthy you want the whole
package but why would I go freaking just
take leftovers God doesn't have his
freakin Bank together come on man how
you gonna take care of me I like that so
pop tip for Paul avoid pornography tip
for Britney go do you know this this is
and by the way if you're watching this
and you you you want to know more about
Paul post your comments on the bottom
Paul's a good look in six one six honey
did rat me out of Miami what you live
knowledge by now you'd be a million
dollars oh yeah let's show Paul can we
show Paul near scuffie show ball in the
air base ball stand-up Jill he shifted -
come over here Paul come around the
camera let them see over here this is oh
this is Paul's button and be honest Paul
Paul raise your right hand put over here
yeah Paul
raised you right in and tell us when is
the last time be honest last night say
last day Paul just get it over yo skip
it
oh come on just be your mom
yeah mom this awesome this is a good
guide okay I mean I'm just kidding
around but I mean you guys should take
the points out it cuz the point is not
to shock you into this you know no
you're saying what what most people
won't talk about that's what you're
saying
it is we already say what most you won't
talk about you don't need to be perfect
you need to be living life man you need
to be living life and living life means
you're expanding like it's an expansion
okay you just you're not just going to
work I know most people go to work
everyday they're not living man they
have succumbed to a schedule and to life
rather than to create you want to be in
the creative part if you want your
marriage to work you got to stay in the
creative but happiness a stem from
creating come on man I get happy when
I'm creating is that not an aligned
message with the entire tour happiness
we talked about it's from creating being
part of a community and having a sense
of ownership and that's something that
being an entrepreneur does for you
that's right when you do that anyways
hey yeah it's been it's been a blast
yeah if you don't follow grant here's
what I suggest by this book we have the
link on the bottom if you don't like to
read do get the mp3 mp3 it's like double
the size of the book I read it and I
start ripping on a chapter that takes
like maybe 15 minutes to read and that
chapter becomes 45 minutes the freaking
audio download is unbelievable the audio
download yeah so we're going to put the
audio down with a Paul let's make it 13
bucks or something and we're going to
put both of them on the bottom as well
follow my twitter youtube subscribe to
his channel
grant can you talk about a little bit
about Grant Cardone TV Grant Cardone TV
the project guys working on because he
was talking about in the idea I want I
want to control my freakin destiny you
know I want to control my destiny I want
to collaborate with other entrepreneurs
people that think like you to create a
network that delivers content that is
productive and conducive to expansion
and when you go to break you don't have
to hear about some depression that you
should be experiencing because you live
on planet or
familiars gravity man gravity's gone
from gravity to a damn everybody's got a
freaking disease now and I just don't
buy it
so the biggest funders for mass TV today
is Big Pharma it pharma spends billions
of dollars to sell trillions of dollars
for the products the way they sell that
product is they know they have to create
a problem for you so you have you they
would say yeah you got you got you
probably got some bipolar [ __ ] going on
me I got some attention deficit disorder
okay you know we both have issues you
know that according to WHO good god I've
read that book maybe they've even given
up on their own book everybody's got a
disorder right so ten million kids this
year are going to be freakin labeled
some disease and put on a drug I mean
it's horrendous man it's horrendous so I
want to network when we control content
push to people it's positive you rise
above the noise you teach people how to
do whatever it takes
it's an entrepreneurial channel and that
doesn't exist in the world today believe
it or not because if you go google how
to start a business do i just try this
exercise Google how to start a business
you'll be more confused in thirty
minutes then you've ever been confused
in your whole life the world needs more
people like you and you bro
come on mom man come on hey grant
cardone follow its material go on Grant
Cardone tv.com am I saying it right yes
are gone yeah tv.com lots of great
content there been a blast hanging out
with them for those of a single guys out
there and single girls out there the
dating advice I've ever given a race is
this don't approach the chick approach
the guys around hey man like your slacks
like your jacket do you're looking good
man
and then you turn away every time
they'll go for Jesus and then you say
let's take a shower is that the line to
use on you by the way
but obviously thirteen months and didn't
work but you followed on that's a closer
hey look if you closed any more just
follow up there's been so much wisdom
today with this interview grant looking
forward to the next sound okay that's
been about to take care yeah hi I'm Paul
scars again and before value tainment
and Pat's interview with Grant Cardone
my dating life was a little suspect but
after listening to Grant and taking his
advice and and I found myself no longer
settling for the shrimp now more in the
stone crab isn't it time that you
started going to dinner and asking for a
table for two instead of one isn't it
time that you walked a dog with somebody
by your side give yourself a chance and
join us every week on Valley taemin and
let's help you find that stone crab